- Poof, Saul Goodman is there.
(bell dinging)
(upbeat music)
My agent called me and said,
they're gonna offer you a role.
It's a great show and you
should say yes to doing it
and, I called a friend.
Not many people had seen
Breaking Bad at that point.
It was towards the end
of season two shooting.
The first season was cut
short by a writer's strike
and I think the show was pretty
much overshadowed by Mad Men
to a great, great extent,
and it hadn't streamed.
So, very few people
knew Breaking Bad until
about the fourth season.
So, I did actually call a
friend I'd been working with
and I said, "Do you know
the show Breaking Bad?,"
and he said, "Best show on TV.
"You've gotta say yes to that."
So I said, "Sure, I'll do it."
You know, it's, I knew it was
lawyer who's kind of a con man
and that just sounded fun and
totally within my wheelhouse
'cause I played Stevie
Grant on Larry Sanders
and it just sounded fun and
I said, "Sure, I'll do it,"
and then they sent me the script
and it had a lot of lines.
You know, it had all these long
runs, you know, of dialogue
and I figured they'd cut those way back,
because in comedy, you don't
tend to monologue like that
and then Vince got on the phone with me,
and because I had read the script, I said,
"I have an idea for this guy's hair.
"I think he should have a comb
over and a mullet in back."
And Vince said, "That sounds like fun.
"I like that idea."
Which was really cool of him.
And, I mean I was scheduled
to do three or four episodes.
They did say they needed me for four,
and I couldn't do the
fourth episode because of,
I was already signed up to
do How I Met Your Mother
and so they invented the
character of Mike Ehrmantraut,
played by Jonathan Banks,
to carry that plot work
that they needed done
in that fourth episode
towards the end of season two.
I think the last episode
it would have been.
But hey, they created Mike
'cause of How I Met Your Mother
so, if you like Mike, thank
How I Met Your Mother.
(foot stomping)
Better call Saul! (laughing)
The first scene I did on
Breaking Bad with Bryan Cranston,
was a big scene where I tell a
monologue about the character
and tell Walter White who
I am and kind of tell him
he doesn't need me and why
don't you just kill your friend
who's in jail.
Somebody in the crew joked,
"Can I get a job on the sequel?"
After we shot that scene.
Right there on the set.
Somebody shouted out, "Can
I get a job on the sequel?"
And everyone laughed because I guess
the character really popped.
Everyone saw the character
as a big, big show
and it was a joke.
And then, a few weeks
later, Vince was in the,
I don't know if it was a few weeks later
or I think it was a year later, when Saul
was coming back and people would joke,
"Do you think he should have a sequel?
"I think I'd like to watch that."
Vince said to me, "Do
you think there's a show
"in this character?
"'Cause I think there is," he said.
And, I said, "I don't know, you know.
"If you think there is, I guess."
I gotta be honest.
I did not think so, not at the time.
'Cause he's just this con man, who cares.
I think in the world of Breaking Bad,
I was very aware that
Saul was more fun to watch
because the stakes were low for Saul
for most of the run of the series.
Nobody's trying to kil him.
Everyone else is gonna die.
Everyone is at some
point losing their family
or they're gonna die.
Not Saul, so it's big,
it's a big game for him,
so he's fun to watch and
he can make wise cracks
and he has a lighter energy
and so people are like,
"Oh, I like Saul and he's funny."
And yeah, he's funny in relation
to these horrible people
who are in hell, but
alone is he fun to watch?
I don't think he's really
worth watching alone.
And when they talked,
Vince and Peter talked
about creating a series, I said,
"You gotta make him likable."
I don't think he's a likable guy.
He's likable in relation
to the world around him
in Breaking Bad.
He's fun to watch, but they
went ahead and did that.
They invented who he
was, who he really was.
Who James McGill was, and
James McGill is likable.
Saul is a front and a
facade and I don't know
if you could say you like
that version of a person,
but the real guy that we've gotten to know
in Better Call Saul is a likable guy
who you can empathize with and champion.
How do I get 'em to call Jimmy McGill?
I don't!
I stay Saul Goodman.
They call the guy they already know.
Well, it's a vastly different performance
in Better Call Saul than in Breaking Bad.
It's way, 100 million times different.
The good thing we had going
for us was in Breaking Bad,
he told Walter White and
he told the audience,
this isn't who I really am.
But then, he never
showed who he really was.
You never saw him go home.
You don't know what his personal life was.
And there were a few times in the course
of the Breaking Bad story where he
showed a deeper dimension.
One time, when he's in the car with Jesse
and a few other of Jesse's friends
and he's dropped off some gifts for Rock
and then he goes and tells Jesse,
you should go in and talk to them.
And he kind of insists that you should.
Now that's not Saul
talking, that's James McGill
because there is nothing
in there for Saul.
There's only danger in it for Saul
to encourage him to go
talk to these people.
And so, that's a moment where you see
this other character peek
through and then at some point,
he also tells Walter White
to quit while he's ahead
which is also not Saul,
because Saul doesn't care
if Walter White gets killed.
He just wants to make money,
so when he tells Walter White,
you know, some people would say,
your position maybe should just back off
and go back to life.
And, that's not Saul talking.
So there were these moments
in the run of Breaking Bad
where you saw Jimmy McGill.
- I'm what?
- You're not a real lawyer!
- It's between, you know, Chuck and Kim.
Those are two really deep
and very well fleshed out
relationships in Better Call Saul.
Chuck is probably the most
interesting and idiosyncratic,
'cause you just don't
see that often played out
in a long form.
It's a sibling relationship
that is that deep and
that scarred and intense.
Those guys are way too close and,
they should leave each other alone,
but they, they both need
something from the other one
and they're not gonna get it.
And Chuck kills himself
as a way to kind of, win.
- [Kim] Jimmy, that's not--
- Yeah, you look at me and
you see Slipping Jimmy.
- I never said that!
- Yeah, but you thought it!
You know, Kim and Jimmy, that
is an amazing relationship
that more than anything in the show,
I think, shows some maturation
from the character of Jimmy.
And shows the character growing up
and I like that a lot.
You know, I'm playing a
character who's much younger
than myself, and one of
the hardest things to play,
I can't do much about
my face and all that,
the makeup people work
on it and do their best,
and the audience has been incredibly kind,
to kind of suspend disbelief
and let me play this guy.
But, one of the hardest
things is to play his level
of immaturity and his outlook on life
and towards other people.
As a person, I read his
part, or I have at times
and gone, "Will you just fucking grow up?"
You know?
But it's a story of a
guy struggling to grow up
and as the time's gone by
and he has changed and arced,
now we get into places
that I can relate to more
and that I can feel,
personally I can feel more sympathy for
and it's really great.
I really like it.
- If this is how you're really feeling.
- [Bob] It is.
- I say sure.
- [Bob] Great, five minutes max.
And then the relationship with Kim,
you know, this last season, season four,
there's these moments where
Jimmy is honest with Kim
and he just tells her truth.
He doesn't try to hide it
or con her or just escape
without being mature about it,
and he tells her the
truth and she listens.
And those things are, those
are, those are the great signs
of two characters growing and
of a couple that should work.
I mean they should be able to make it work
which is of course gonna
be tragic if they can't
which I assume they can't.
I mean, I assume something big goes wrong
and of course I don't
wanna give anyway spoilers
but I'm seriously talking as a fan,
that I don't think that
Saul Goodman in Breaking Bad
is going home to Kim Wexler.
I dread what could happen to her.
But if something really tragic happens,
then I don't see how he could go on,
so I don't know, I
don't know what happens.
And I almost think it
would be more tragic,
and I'm just spit balling here as a fan,
if she and he were separated
but still carrying on
in Albuquerque and he, you know,
she had to drive by his billboard.
He had to drive by her law office.
I think it's easier to
maintain now than it was
and the reason is because
in the character's story
he's decided to very
consciously compartmentalize
his worst instincts and call
them Saul Goodman and be that
and when he's that, he's
that, and when he's home,
he's Jimmy McGill and he's a person
that Kim Wexler can trust and love
and so, because he's now made this choice,
like I'm not gonna just
kind of go through life
and struggle with all these urges,
I'm gonna put all my bad urges right here.
I'm gonna dress for it
and I'm gonna be that guy
and don't expect anything good from him
and then when I go home,
I'll take off my tie
and my lime green socks and I
will be a good, this good guy
who, you know, is capable
of honest interaction
and caring and so in a way,
it's gotten easier now.
Because it's easier for Jimmy.
I mean I think the character feels lighter
and more energetic because
he goes, "I figured it out.
"I figured it out.
"I know what I have to do.
"I have to play this part."
So I, I find season five
to be a more upbeat,
energetic, and kind of, he's
clearer in what he's doing
and I think he's grown emotionally.
Now, the question is, can
a person make that work
in the real world or can a person do that?
That's what they're asking.
You know, can you separate
yourself out like that
and live a bifurcated existence like that?
And we'll, we'll see what the show says.
(gentle music)